uh thanks everybody for coming
so my name is davis
i work as a software engineer at
iterative.ai
which is a
company that pays me for this trip so
let me just ask one slide about it
we work on building
envelopes tools open source tools
trying to fill the gap between the
existing software engineering stack
and machine learning practitioners
we are a fully remote team
as you can see for the from the map
distribution
yeah we have open positions of all kinds
if you would like to join check the
website or talk with me later
i have a bunch of stickers
you can bash around like if they were
drunk
all right so what do i mean by
making envelopes and cool again i am not
sure but i have to ask one is life to
explain it because it's the title
so i think the idea came from the
evolution of devops
uh
from my perspective
devops started with from
uncool era
with jenkins and maybe other tools that
i am not familiar with
and this is the uncool phase because
not many people were interested
in this matter
and then eventually
the interest started to grow
exponentially and so a huge number of
startups open source
approaches
big companies working on providing
specialized devops solutions
so i call this the cool
era
the issue with this is that i believe
that the end user experience started to
degrade because now you need to pick
one of many
of these tools and you need to discover
how to integrate with your workflow
and then the current status i think is
the
uncool again ega
where the major git providers
git server providers like gitlab and
github
have consolidated their own approach to
devops
and
uh the other tools i are kind of left
behind now
i think this is the uncool era because
while it's not so popular to talk about
debobs because it's kind of soft
i think it's a really good state
in my experience github actions
are the first tool where i have seen a
researcher actually carrying or being
able to extend a ci or cd workflow
maybe it's just my circles of people
that i know but
this is the first time i have seen this
kind of interest
so yeah a little overview of what
envelopes in my perspective
i don't think there is a universal
definition of envelopes and i think it's
very dependent on the use case
and what i am about to explain is truly
from my experience
so i got into mlbs coming from a
researcher background
as researchers we didn't really care
about devops at all we were worried
about compiling
siano or whichever framework we was
at that time
and we didn't really care about cicd
software engineering best practices i
was the one who started to worry about
it
getting interested in this and i guess
i was a little annoying to the devops
team asking for stuff that they didn't
deliver so that made me a good candidate
to
get the title of the envelopes guy
and i have to go into this quest of
discovering what this means
so i
asked around to my fellow researchers
and to myself
what we really want from devops from
envelope sorry
and from our perspective what the first
thing i
discover is that
this thing called reproducibility
actually means that it was very annoying
for a researcher
taking over a project
that was from a previous researcher that
for some reason is no longer in the
company or he
has been assigned to a different project
it was very difficult to catch up with
the current status and discover how how
all the configuration data model and
pipeline was set up
so i guess this is what people call
reproducibility
and then there is automation which is
basically
that
ideally the researcher
should be able to focus on doing
research
and not having to manually trigger a
pipeline in order to retrain the model
when new data arrives
but we were in this situation where
researchers were also in charge of
retraining the model and this was a
manual process and ideally it was like
do
we would like to automate this part so
we could focus on doing research
yes so
i think pretty much all researchers i
met i agree on these goals
so i went on a new quest of discovering
how to do this
and yeah first option uh we found and we
tried was end-to-end machine learning
platforms offers by the big cloud
providers it kind of makes sense to try
this first because we were already using
many of the services from these cloud
providers
i found a little
quite a few actually issues that i
didn't like at all
the most important one for in my opinion
was that these
platforms isolate the researchers from
the software engineering stack
and i really wanted actually researchers
to be involved in software engineering
best practices
so
this didn't feel like a good option to
achieve that
in addition we have some projects where
these uh scalability
features provided us by these platforms
make sense but then we also have like a
majority of small projects where this
was completely overkill
and
but you cannot opt out from these uh
services in this platform you have to be
buy the food package
and finally
for obvious reason because it's their
business model uh
once you build your stock around one of
these cloud providers
they are not going to make your life
easier if you want to integrate an
external tools uh external tool or if
you want to switch to another provider
i am not saying that using an instant
machine learning platform is not the
right solution
and
if you are a big company
which already has
a lot of services in
one of these platforms so you are
already attached to this vector vendor
locking
maybe this is the right solution for you
all right and then the next alternative
was exploring the
widely vast open source space of mlaps
tools
i think the image
talks for itself
it just does it's just that there are so
many tools for so many different scenes
and nobody really explains you how to
connect these tools or even what tools
do you need
that this was just a cumbersome to
explore all the possibilities
so
we took a step back went to the devops
team and asked them okay if we are using
devops for software engineering
why can't you devops team extends your
tools
so we can
do envelopes with them
which is basically what this meme
is about
and they ask that you already have some
sort of
similar workflow tools
available in the envelopes space for
example queue flow
but the issue is that researchers were
really proficient using github actions
and for some reason i have no nothing
against google flow i think it's a great
tool but for some reason they were not
so proficient
trying to do the same things around
coop's flow
so many blog posts
i think it's called it's linked at the
bottom
and the first reason they give for a
devops not been not sufficient for
machine learning is that you in addition
to source code you also need to version
the data parameters and probably model
and it turns out that i'm starting to
sell our tools okay
and it turns out that there is this
fancy tool called dvc or the version
control that allows you to version data
code parameters all together through git
the other point i
made
in this briefcase is that
many machine learning projects require
hardware
that that is not usually available in
the
cicd
space
and there is another tool made by the
same company called continuous machine
learning or cml
that acts
powerful machines with gpus or whatever
inside your existing devops cicd
workflow
all right so with this uh
which
if someone wants to follow the worship
uh we are about to start
uh the
toy project that i choose to build this
workflow around is an automatic
usu labeler
basically because i wanted to try having
face library
and because we have an interest
interesting data set in the actual dbc
repository where we have over 3 000
issues
and we have a bunch of labels that we
use to categorize so the idea is that we
are going to build a model that takes
the title of the issue
and is going to predict which label
should be assigned
here is the link
to the workshop i am going to give you a
few seconds to
go there
and
if
while during the workshop you face some
issues please raise your hand and i can
stop and try to solve it
but for the questions please ask them in
this platform
slider
so i can answer in the answer
so i can assume that everybody is in the
everybody who wants to follow the
workshop is in the github repository
please raise your hand so
yeah
all right
so
a quick quick overview of the high level
idea of the project is that we have a
data source
which lives in github in this case is
the dbc repository where people open new
issues every day
and in this repository we are going to
use github dbc and cml
to first construct a data set
to train a hug in phase model that we
are going to eventually
ship
inside the docker container so it could
be deployed anywhere
including the original github repository
the tools we are about to use are dbcdbc
live and cml
by iterative and the high high-end phase
transformers
so the current status is what i call
local reproducibility if you click on
this link
[Music]
in this
current status we have a dvc pipeline
there was a great talk yesterday about
dbc pipelines i i don't think i have the
time to cover what
how it works
but there are links to the good
documentation and you can ask me
questions later
the idea is that the pipeline is defined
in a dbc xml file you can click on
explore how this pipeline looks like i
hope that it looks simple enough for you
to understand how the pipeline is being
built
the pipeline has a first stage
that
is going to get
issues the issues from the dbc
repository
there are a bunch of parameters to
configure this stage
and all the other stages and they are
defined in the params the jammer file
so the first stage
names and get data it's going to use all
the parameters of the file inside the
data section
we are going to fetch issues from the
iterative
how is this
size
right
so we are going to fetch issues from the
iterative dbc repository we are only
going to
select a subset of the labels
this is what you are supposed to do also
in your in your real life projects and
don't try to solve the whole problem
from the beginning start with a minimal
viable problem so we select this three
subset of labels and we are going to get
the issues
uh from uh
the first day of
2021
to the first day of
april
of this year
and this is just a way to indicate where
we are going to store the outputs
so this is the data that is configured
by those
parameters then we have another stage
which is called split data and i assume
that you understand what is how to do
which is split the data set into a train
and evaluation splits
then we have the training stage that
uses harmful trade model and finally an
evaluation stage i think these pipelines
enable
local reproducibility in a way that if
you clone
these
first steps are optional you can run
locally
it might going to take a while
and we are all using the same internet
connection so you are guessing that
fetching the issues from
github
might collapse the network
but
don't worry if you don't run these steps
you are still able to follow the next
steps
so if you clone this repository locally
and you store the requirements which
also might collapse the network if you
are wrong at the same time
you can reproduce the full pipeline with
a single command called dbc repro
so
i have this workshop
repository clone locally
and i have already installed the
requirements and
i already have run the pipeline
so the thing with this dvc ripper and
dvc pipelines is that once you run
for the first time your pipeline is
going to store the outputs in a local
dbc cache
so unless you modify
one of the dependencies of
one stage
that stage is not going to be rerun
so because between the last dbc review
and the one i have just run
i didn't change anything
the command does nothing because all the
states are they didn't change
if i go ahead and
change the number of epochs from 15 to
10 to 10
and i run dvc repo
it's going to skip the first two stages
and rerun the training stage
with these new parameters
uh
it didn't it doesn't take
very much to train the model it's a very
small model and a very small data set
so it's going to rerun the stages from
the pipeline that are dependent on this
change in this case because the
valuation stage depends on the training
outputs even so i train i only change a
parameter from the training stage it's
going to rerun the training and the
evaluation stage
and just a simple pipeline that is built
using dependencies and outputs
so once i have run this pipeline
you can see in the local changes that it
generates a bunch of tsb files and json
files which are basically what
individuals call metrics and plots
these metrics and plots are playing a
text files
and
because they are small enough you can
track them with git
uh the plots you might or might not want
to track with it because they can
be
a little big
but in this case for the sake of
simplicity i am tracking them with it
the funny
file to care about is this dbc log file
which is basically storing the hashes
of the outputs that we just
generate
so
this file is shipped inside your github
your git and repository so
as long as you have a local cache
which i have in my computer are you are
going to have in your computer if you
run the command
these
outputs can be retrieved from the local
cache so the stages don't need to be
recomputed
this is
why i call local reproducibility because
you can reproduce the pipeline as long
as you have access to the local cache
dbc plots and metrics i already show and
we also i have to make this publicity
we also have this tool called a studio
which is a way to visualize all these
ppc related files in a nicer way so this
is just
to use this you all you need to do is to
connect your github repo
with studio and is going to parse the
commits and look for the files to show
here
so
as you can see it can differentiate
the values of the parameters and
metrics
from other outputs and it's also able to
render the plots
that are just plain tsb files in our
local git repository
all right
so
i have run the pipeline locally and now
i can track all the outputs with dbc
sorry with it and share with other
people
so i just ask all these files to get
and push them
so later on if i clone this repository i
could reproduce the pipeline and nothing
will happen
you might notice that we have some
outputs that are being hit ignored
because they are too big to be tracked
by git
and that's the reason why we need a
bigger ship
so this is the next step which is the
first you are about to do something
which is called shares reproducibility
in order to be able to have access to
these
large files and directories that we have
generated dbc provides a thing called
dbc remote and how it works is that
in git you are going to track and push
and pull the small metadata files
which were the dbc lock i showed you
before
and they are going to be linked to the
actual
files in your local cache
introducing a dbc remote allows you to
run dbc push and dbc pull commands to
this remote so you can keep your git
repository and your big
data files in sync
in order to ask a new remote i think
that the simple
thing we could do is
i assume that you all have a google
account
so you can go go to your google drive
account and create a new folder
which is going to serve as our
dbc remote
you can delete it later and it's not
going to take much space
if you don't have a google drive remote
then i am sorry i didn't consider that
so the important thing is that
once you have this new folder created
you can go ahead and copy paste the last
part of the url
which is the identifier of the folder
so if you are following i
i forgot
you are supposed to be working on a fork
of the repository
maybe i forgot to tell
but i didn't fork it myself
and i already have a fork
which is going to be up outdated
sorry about that
all right
so
in your fork
um
this is not mandatory but you can open
your repo
changing dot com by that dev and you
will enter the
web editor that the github provides
and i'm fine i find this more convenient
for editing files
all right
going back to the docs
i think we are here so we have a new
google drive folder that we are going to
use as dbc remote
in order to ask it
to our project
from the web we can edit this file
called dbc slash config
and we can
ask this
content
so inside.dbc config
i copy paste this content
and i replace this
by my
google drive
url
so this is how your dbc's last config is
supposed to
look and this is what connects
and tells dbc that you are going to use
this google drive as a remote
[Music]
just checking
is
whoever is follow is at this step
no okay
is there an issue or
the connection is terrible
even for the editor
i mean you can skip the running the
pipeline locally to save connection and
you can just jump into this step
if the web editor is not working i guess
you can you could also edit directly
from the github interface
so has anyone reaches this point
raise your hand please
not many
alright so i guess i can take one
question if there is some
to give some time
there is one all right
so
maybe you
saw the question my mic
so the question is why not
can can you read it or not yeah so the
question is what why not get a large
file system instead of a dvc remote and
that's a very good question
and we have a page in our documentation
[Music]
which is
called
related technologies
and
here is the answer
that i can just read so
the difference between the git lfs and
dvc remote is that dbc does not require
any special server like it lfs
so you could not set up without
additional work a google drive remote as
a git lfs server you have to do a bunch
of stuff
and dvc does not ask any dbc
any git hooks in your repo if you don't
want to
and
yeah
another thing that is not mentioning
here maybe i can improve the
documentation is that
the dbc hashes and remotes are connected
to the pipeline
and the stages
and you cannot have this direct
connection and reference in git lfs
by default
i think that's the answer
all right
how are we doing with this uh adding a
remote
yes
no
i i wonder what's the issue or what's
the question
if when you run the pipeline locally
yeah
i forgot to say that
because you are fetching issues from a
github repository
you are
if you want to run this locally you have
to generate a personal access access
token so why not all
can just skip the first step of running
this locally and
jump directly into
working in the browser and adding this
dvc remote
in the browser
to
remind you you just have to create a new
folder
in your google drive
copy the url
and create this content
in dbc folder
config file
replacing this stuff with the
corresponding id of your
google drive folder
i am sorry
because you are supposed to each one
connect your own dvc remote
otherwise we will be beating all the
same
repo the idea is that in your fork you
put your own dbc remote with your own
google drive folder that you can delete
later
we are all going to do the same but we
are going to duplicate all the results
in its google drive account
and i think yeah i am doing this on my
own fork
so how are we going are we
have we as this remote
i see some yes yes yes yes okay
so once you have these changes you can
commit the file
adding
google drive remote
all right
so this is how you ask the dbc remote
from the web
if you are running this locally i
encourage not to do it because of the
connection
you could you could do this
also from the commands live interface
with this command
and there is a link if you want more
information about how this works
so because now we have added this dvc
remote we have enabled what i call
shares reproducibility
the idea is that before in our local
machine
after we run dvc repo
repro
we could ask and commit the changes
trackers by git and we could push them
with git push now we can also run dbc
push to upload the associated big files
to the dbc remote
so in
if now we go to a different machine
we can run git pool to get the changes
and we can also run dbc pool to get the
data set and the model generated by the
previous run
so we have enabled a way to share the
full pipeline including data and
outputs
but still working in this git
like workflow
the the good thing is that
if you want to use a different remote
you just have to go to the
documentation and check what are the
credentials requires
we support pretty much
all the major cloud providers as remote
including amazon buckets is your
google drive away which we are using and
you can also go creative and use
custom remotes in your essay in your own
servers with ssh
http and a lot of different protocols
if one of the remotes is not supported
the only requirement is that it's
compliant with an fspec
file system so if you know what is that
a good chance is that you can implement
your custom remote
but the commands and the workflow would
be the same the only thing that would
change is how this config file
looks
all right so that's shares
reproducibility
raise your hands
if you have completed this
you are not supposed to run the commands
you are just supposed to set up this for
the next step so
everybody has like edits this config
file
yeah
the content of whatever you're supposed
to copy paste is here
in the
is there another question sir
sorry can you repeat
okay what we have accomplished with this
is that we have enabled
the dbc push and dbc pull commands
so
before from my machine
i am researcher a if i update on hyper
parameter and i run dbc repo
there are these small files that can be
tracked by git and pushes by date
but we could not share we didn't have a
way to share the data set and the model
right
yeah this is how you would do it from
the command line and
well
you can actually have multiple remotes
per project
on
each individual file can have a custom
remote but in this case it's very simple
we are going to put everything in the
same
dbc drive
google drive sorry
so locally
because i was editing in the web
in the web
oh this is not my fork
all right
so i'm going into online reproducibility
uh
we have to grant uh we have to create a
gift github personal
access token because of the error you
faced before
which is good that our first stage is
going to fetch a lot of issues from
github so you are going to reach the
limit of the api
but you can generate a personal token
if you go to your profile
settings
at the bottom
[Music]
developer settings
personal access token
i create this one but i can delete
and you click on generate a new token
you give it a meaningful name
and you don't need to grant any
permissions you just need a personal
stocking so you can just generate
once you generate
you can copy
the value of the token
and back in your
repository
sorry in your fork
you can go to
settings
and create an action secret
secrets
actions
i am going to repeat this process okay
i'm just doing it myself
personal
github token and i copy paste the value
okay i am going to repeat now the
process
i am in github
i go to my profile
settings
at the very bottom
there is the developer settings section
at the very bottom there is the personal
access tokens
and we generate a new one
we give it a name
and we don't need to click any of the
other stuff
we just generate the token
this is uh
this
house is going uh id is going to appear
here you need to copy the value
okay
and now going back to your fork
i am in my fork now
i am i go to settings
we are in secrets actions
and we
create a new repository sequence
we paste the value that we have just
copied
and we name it
personal
github
talking
and we click ask secret
i already have it so i
cannot do it
this is just because i am stupid and i
created a data set that requires github
api
to bypass the limits
but here it is
do you all have your personal access
token stored as a secret
great
so we are going to do a similar
step but now
in order to grant github workflows
access to our dbc remote so we need to
give github access to this dbc
google drive folder
so
i have two options if you are working
from the web
this is super hacky
but i added here a link to a google
kolaf
i am in the
docs folder online reproducibility
document
and in the section grant did have access
to the dbc remote
there is a link for a google collab
i am just realizing that i made my life
so much harder
than it could be
for you to follow this worship
but
i basically have a google collab so you
can get the right content content of the
credentials from the web
uh
just run
all this cell all the
i think sorry if you reach the google
collab
please
create a copy
and run the cells
here you are supposed to copy paste the
google drive url
in the second cell
and you are supposed to run all the
other cells
to finally get
oh sorry yeah
when you once you run this uh
before the last cell you are going to be
prompt
to go to this url and grant dvc
access to your google drive
and eventually it's going to give you
this authorization code
that you can copy paste
into
the cell
and it's going to retrieve finally the
access token
so this process is a little tedious
if
are you all in the google collab
yes
are you facing some issues
the important part is that you paste
your url of your google drive remote in
this cell
you are supposed to store a cup
copy
of this collab in your account
uh it's actually just because i was
focused on being able to run from the
browser but if you actually install the
dependencies
and follow the previous steps the first
thing you run dbc push
you are going to reach this
google authentic authentication page
and you are going to copy paste the
authorization code
so locally you should have this
credentials file
stored in nagitiknor folder
and this is the content you need
to
grant github access to the dbc or amount
is there a question
no questions is there in-person
questions
all right yeah i am waiting so everyone
has this final output with the right
access token
have you all run the google column
yeah
yes
kinda
what's kinda
uh
i mean it's supposed to be in your fork
and this collab is supposed to be on
your account
i choose not have access to anything
yeah but only for that folder
yeah i mean uh we i have been filmed so
you can tweet me
show me if i do something
but yeah it's only spot for the folder
so do you all have the generated this
final token
with your
google drive url
cool so you
copy the or the full
json
the final output you copied
and backing your fork
we are going to store this in a new
secret so the same process we went
before we went to settings
secrets actions
we create a new repository secret
we paste
the whole
json authentication stuff
and
let me check what is supposed to be the
name
all right yeah it's year drive
credentials data
thank you
it's supposed to be in the notebook
somewhere
so this is how your secret is supposed
to look have you created this secret
yes raise your hands or something
yeah
all right
so with this finally
github is supposed to be able to fetch
issues from the dbc repository and have
access to the google drive remote
so we can go back to the online
reproducibility
step
and we can create a
workflow that runs whenever whenever a
new pr is created in this repository the
idea is that whenever a new pr is
created we are going to run the
the dbc pipeline inside the github
actions runner
and we are going to pull and push data
to the dbc remote
and we are going to use cml
to
send a report
that will be posted as a comment in the
pr
that will
it's supposed to look like this
containing all the changes of the
metrics parameters
and plots
okay
so the warfare that you need to copy
paste is here
i can copy all the content
and the idea is that in the web editor
you create a new file under github slash
workflows
calls on pr the name is not important
the important part is that it's
located and then under github workflows
so i copies all the content from this
snippet
and i am back in my editor
and inside github workflows
i create a new file
and i name it on pr.jaml
i paste
all the content
here
now i am trying to
explain very quickly what's
supposed to happen
so this is uh the syntax for a github
actions workflow and we are saying that
it's going to be triggered when a new
prs gets created and we can also trigger
this workflow manually
what is the what this workflow does is
that it installs the requirements
and it runs the
pipeline
pulling all the
necessary data if there is some data in
the remote the first time you are going
to run this is not going to pull
anything
but
subsequent runs
it's supposed to pull the requires data
and all the stuff all this stuff about
secrets it was
all for
this step to be able to fetch
and put data into this google drive
folder
and the github token is just so the
github api doesn't complain
so this is the same thing that we run
and then what we do is inside the
workflow we push the changes to dbc to
google drive
because we have yeah
so if you do that because of the secrets
no you are supposed to create the fork
on your own
appear on your own
repository with a ton of people working
yeah you are no i guess
if you want that setup you are not
supposed to work in separate for forks
you are supposed to work on the same
repository
or i mean
there must be ways that you can trigger
workflows from other repositories i
think there's a repository dispatch
options
but i am not super familiar with github
actions
so we are
all this is happening in the github
runner and after the pipeline has run we
push the changes to google drive
and we have cml cml
utilities which are meant to
track
because we are updating files inside
github actions we have on the one hand
files that we want to share through dbc
and this is the dbc push but we also
have these files tracked by git that we
also want to
update and this is what the cml pr
functionality does it's going to create
another pr
targeting our original pr
that we can just accept and it's going
to merge these changes which are
basically the files that before when i
run locally i get others and committees
manually
and finally all this code is only
twisted below all is just to generate
the fancy report that is going to be
posted
uh as a comment
so just copy paste the content into
github workflows on pr
and
save the changes
so address
or pr
workflow
just commit the
changes and in your work in your fork
now you are supposed to have
a file
with that content
how are we doing do we all have this
file
yes
yes
more yeses
yeah
so because now we have this file from
the git and
from the github github interface
i go to the parameter.jammer file
i edit
and then i am going to chase
epochs from 10 to
8 i don't know
important thing is that you create a new
branch and a pr instead of directly
committing the changes
so at the bottom you select create a new
branch for this commit and start a pull
request
so i click this
and i create a new pr
when
when you reach this point
github actions is supposed to trigger
the workflow that we have just created
which is happening right now
so with this we have allow us anyone
with access to the repository
to trigger the same pipeline that we
were running locally
and
they are able to
run custom experiments
from the webs the web interface and
experiments can be managed with regular
git workflow you can decline or upset
accept these prs this pr is going to
take a while to run
you can just check that it's going to
run the dbc pipeline and share the
changes and all that
because run the dbc pipeline
oh beautiful
unexpected error
what is this
yeah
it was supposed to work
let me quick check if i mess up
something
my ssh probably but
has anyone created the
workflow
yeah i don't know what is this
i actually think
that i
say too quickly
that this talk
no it cannot be
yeah it's failing in this step
actions check out
so i don't know if it has to be with a
fork or something
no it's here
here
funny stuff
so luckily
i think i have an actual repository
working
somewhere
well i can show you how this this is
supposed to look
a custom runner
sorry
is
so we are entering the click ops
approach
are you saying that if you trigger
manually
it works
yeah i mean
i am going to unarchive this repository
[Music]
so i don't know what is going on that's
the issue when a researcher is doing
devops
but yeah
if you go to this link
workshop
on cool envelopes
solution
there must be a lot of close sprs
and
actually
i know that it works because it works in
this repository
so let me try to do it here
epochs 8.
well the idea is that
if you have in your team someone that
knows github actions can help you get
this workflow run running
i don't really know what's going on
because i try this yesterday and it
works
but
going back to the narrative
the idea is that if you update the
parameters
create a new branch and trigger a new pr
this pipeline and workflow that you were
running locally is supposed to be
running in these github runners
but for some reason it's not working now
it might be because of
i run inside our organization and some
something is different
but yeah i am going to have this
pr running in this solution
repository
that you can access because now it's
public
and with this eventually if you get it
working
you are going to achieve online
reproducibility because anyone can
reproduce the pipeline from the github
interface
as long as there are no errors
the thing is that
the github runners might not be powerful
enough that was one of the things that
the devops
versus envelopes
blog post
was saying
and for that there's this feature that i
was smart enough to not include in this
workshop because
is adding another layer of complexity
but it allows you to
use self-hosted runners
inside github or gitlab
and these self-hosted runners
are supposed to be
a cloud instance from any of the major
cloud providers so your workflow will be
the same
but instead of running on the github
runners
you ask this step
that creates create uses cml runner to
create a new cloud instance
and then the steps below for example
they're running the dbc pipeline
is going to run on
this self-hosted
runner that lives in the cloud instance
okay so cml is going to take take care
of
bringing a
[Music]
granting github
access to this cloud instance
and after you finish this
workflow the cloud instance is supposed
to be killed
so this is a cml self-hosted runners and
if you
you could do this same workflow we are
doing
but we will be relying on klaus instance
for the computation and training of the
model
now this is also not working and i am
pretty sure now that this is a bug with
the actions check out or something
got it
yeah
sorry about that i swear to god that i
ran this yesterday and it worked
and i didn't change the goal
and you can find
are you serious
[ __ ]
apologies
nobody's fault we all cope and we all
break things
but come on
all right
it's not my fault i i guess i could say
yeah
in the solutions you can look for
pr's that before this amazing change
we're working
i close all of those but yeah here's an
example where i create a similar pr
updating the parameters
the workflow actually run it's the same
that you copy pasted
and the cml report looks like this so
it's a
github comment with the difference of
the metrics the parameters
the plots
and
it actually contains that all so if you
merge this
on the one hand the google drive remote
is going to have the right versions of
the data and models and your github is
going to have the right metadata files
and parameter files and everything so
the idea is that you can handle
this experimentation in a similar way as
you handle
source code i guess
right
so the issue is that the next steps rely
on
having a successful run
of the previous workflow so i am going
to walk you through and whenever this
back or whatever this fixes maybe you
can try it
so
the idea is that because we have
successfully run a workflow
in github
and github has access to our dbc remote
we can also include a new workflow that
is also not going to work because it
uses the same actions checkout stuff
to deploy the model so the idea is that
the model gets automatically deployed
from the main branch
without manual intervention
in this case
what i choose to do is to
use a docker file
[Music]
inheriting from the hanging phase
transformers
image
and what this docker file does is it
copies the
model
which is located in the output string
this file is tracked by dbc
so it doesn't exist in your
machine or wherever you are running this
unless you run dbc pool
so if you are in the main branch and you
run dbc pool
dbc is going to get the right version of
the model from the google drive remote
and is going to copy
into this
docker container
then we have an inference
script that is very simple you can check
it out later
and we provide an entry point for this
so
once we have this docker file in our
repository
we can use
uh
i i am reusing an existing github
actions workflow that's the thing i like
about these actions is that you have a
marketplace where you can copy paste
existing workflows so if you search for
a github workflow for deploying docker
images it looks exactly like this
the only change is that before building
the actual docker image
i run dbc pool
to get the right version of the model
from the google drive
remote
and with this i am building a docker
image that is going to be stored
in the github container registry
containing the latest version of the
model that someone train and merge into
the
main branch
i think that because of this solution
repository you can actually try
so whenever you run this workflow once
you merge and once you create a new
commit this workflow is going to be
triggered a new docker image is going to
be created and registered
into this github package
so from your local machine or whatever
you should be able to run these commands
and get the docker image
that contains the latest
version of the model
i think i can run can run this actually
so this this docker image has an entry
point with this infinite script the idea
is that if you pass
an example
issue title
it's supposed to return the prediction
of the model in json format
so if you run this command from
whichever part you want
and
i actually launch docker so this works
if you don't have the image locally it's
going to get the latest version from the
github github package registry
and yeah you have access to the latest
model that some researcher trains
with this docker image
i assume this is not working yet
the url is wrong
so that the ploy is iterative
workshop and
cool envelopes
so this is
the url that you can
see
in the github
when whenever you are in the solution
repository
like this
the latest version of the image is
accessible through this url
so i am running this locally in my
machine
telling to use that image to predict a
label for this issue
and it predicts that the issue the label
is a data sync issue which is correct
because
yeah it's related to dvc pool
i can try this with other inputs
like
dbc x
files on github
and it predicts that the label is
experiments
so this provides
researchers with an
easy way
to
make the latest version of the model
available for
whoever wants to use it
the final step of the deployment in this
use case is that you can create yet
another github workflow that whenever a
new issue is created
it's going to
run the same commands that i have just
run locally
using the latest version of the model
and it's going to predict and assign a
label to the
to the issue that was just created this
workflow is supposed to be triggered
whenever a new issue gets created
so in if in the
solution
repository
i create a new issue
with the same stuff
saying
title
the workflow that you are supposed to
commit and push in
this repository
is going to trigger a new actions
a new run of the issue labor workflow
because we just create a new issue
and this is going to run
the prediction
and eventually it's going to assign a
new label
to the
issue that has been created i am not
sure how much this is supposed to take
and there are a lot of stuff that
because i am not a devops guy i am not
doing but you could use github cache
to cast some layers of the docker image
you could cache the
requirements of your project so you are
not constantly installing the same the
same dependencies each time a new pr
gets created
all right
so this workflow has finished so the
issue that i created now has a label
called experiments
and this was created with the latest
model that that is available in the main
branch
that a researcher could have
created via a pr
if this
stuff with the checkout action
didn't happen
so this is the deployment part and
finally just a minor extension of the
workflow we already have
is
that
because github actions workflow actually
allows you to run prs on different
triggering
we can use a chrome schedule to
automatically run the same process at
the end of each day
because new issues get added to the dbc
repo
every day
this workflow is going to be very
similar to the one that we trigger when
we manually create a pr
but in this case we are using the set
pattern functionality of the dbcs
program
to update this parameter that we have
that that sets the boundary of the final
date that we want to fetch issues from
and we are going to set to the current
date that this workflow is
being run
so this is going to fetch a new data set
from the dbc repo it's going to train a
new model
it's going to publish that model
and it's going to create a pr
so every day when we are going to create
a new pr
a new version of the model using the
same configuration that is merged on the
main branch
whenever a researcher
finds a new parameter that works better
it's going to get merged into the main
branch so this new model is going to be
retrained with this new parameter that
is supposed to work better
and this is like like the final step of
the automation which is that
where yeah
the researcher is never going to have to
trigger the model again you could leave
the same model with the same
configuration just being retrained
as new data arrives
[Music]
and yeah i think that's the end of my
worship i am truly sorry that
we face
this issue all together
but the
solution repository is publicly
available
and there is
proof history that this works at some
point
and whenever this is you get fixes your
fork is also supposed to work and you
can modify wherever you want
so
i think that's everything
[Applause]
all right
so ask your questions either by a slider
or just raise your hand
can you elaborate a little bit on what
the cml2 now
all right
so this cml provides us different set of
utilities
the major one is the self-hosted runner
the idea to have a powerful machine to
run inside your github workflow in
addition it provides another utilities
for a
publishing markdown reports
as part of a
as github or gitlab comments and this is
the sense comment utility
that we were using we were also using
this
pr functionality
that all it does is
you provide them with some paths of
files that you updated during your
workflow and it's going to create a new
pr
with those changes
otherwise all these
changes to git tracked files will be lo
would be lost inside the workflow so
it's a convenience ability to
enable this workflow or to still be only
on github
okay
next question
so the idea is basically to also have
some kind of link to your data tracking
changes etc also in the github
repository the way you track the source
code
so basically you're seeing this also as
part of the source code
because the model also depends on the
data right
what i didn't get yet is if there is
changes in the base data you will have
like a lot of
stuff on your file system right and the
links are just uh created by these dbc
meta files right
but you will still have multiple copies
of the data right yeah like it's not
like an iterative approach where you
just
always add new data to it but it's
really like separate data sets
yeah also because in this case
the nature of the data set is
incremental because we're fetching
issues
but um on the one hand
dbc handles deduplication at the file
level
so
uh unless the title of the issue has
changed even so i am fetching these
issues
whenever i do the dbc push because the
hashes of the files individual files are
are still the same those files are not
going to be duplicated in your remote
so this is all handled
yeah
would it be easy to uh integrate checks
into these uh pipelines for example like
checking that the accuracy has actually
increased in the news model yeah i mean
because all this is happening
is this happening in github actions
workflow you can
ask any step that you want
and
so
after being create after i have created
this report
you could ask an additional step that
runs a custom python script that checks
that the accuracy has improved or
something so all the data here
the model is here you could evaluate
another custom
check
you could
set up
an automatic merge of this pr
based on that rule
okay
another question
okay thank you very much david yeah
[Applause]